it's been an interesting couple of years
for former Republican congressman joe
scarborough he's the co-host along with
his new fiance mika brzezinski of the
MSNBC program morning joe he was pretty
much pushed into the middle of a bunch
of controversies when then candidate and
now president donald trump was
criticizing him criticized by him joe
scarborough was on the forefront of
questioning the mental health of donald
trama used to be such great friends at
some point they were presumably friends
donald trump would invite joe
scarborough tomorrow logo along with
Mika Brzezinski who of course Donald
Trump criticized for bleeding badly from
an alleged facelift recently we also
learned about morning Joe's engagement
to his co-host a couple of months ago so
anyway he's had a pretty pretty exciting
couple of years the latest is that joe
scarborough is leaving the republican
party he's becoming an independent ooh
wow big big news here is his
announcement on last night stephen
colbert program presented as a
completely spontaneous revelation but
clearly planned in advance take a look
judge curio when he called the guy from
indiana he attacked him said he can
never be fair because he was Hispanic
Republicans didn't come out and say I
can never vote for Donald Trump because
he's a racist time and time and time
again they turned the other way and
they're doing the same thing now and
it's actually disgusting and you have to
ask yourself what exactly is a
Republican Party willing to do how far
they willing to go how much of this
country and our values are they willing
to sell out but aren't you a Republican
I am a Republican but I'm not going to
be a Republican anymore I've got to
become an independent Stephen Colbert
really teeing it up there for Joe to
knock out of the park
does this feel a more like a PR move for
him as a broadcaster than anything truly
political I mean okay it's kind of cool
he's leaving the Republican Party but it
just feels so forced and staged and
meaningless maybe it is a microcosm for
what's going on in the Republican Party
because if you
back in 1962 Ronald Reagan left the
Democratic Party famously said that I
didn't leave the Democratic Party they
left me maybe the same things going on
here with Joe Scarborough and the
Republican well you're right in that the
Republican Party has shifted from being
a party that I disagreed with on
economic policy to a sort of cartoonish
group of corrupt and depraved extremists
and the Republican Party it
I don't think conservatism is even the
primary characteristic of the Republican
Party anymore right I mean it the values
of press freedom and small government
and states right in the free market the
Republican Party now likes press freedom
when it's pressed that they like its
small government except when they want
to set up crony deals with defense
contractors and massive government
spending it states rights except when
states do things that the Republican
Party doesn't like it's free market
except for the industries they want to
prop up it's a free market of ideas
except when the ideas aren't ones that
they like like for example what science
says about climate change so in a sense
if joe scarborough's views haven't
evolved from being a sort of
center-right to somewhat more right
republican you've got a republican party
now that is basically about
authoritarian corporate feudalism and i
understand that that does make sense and
many of those reasons that you're
listing is why joe scarborough is
choosing to leave the republican party
he brought up the muslim band
trump's treatment of judge curio like
kowtow to racism and also how george w
bush went from having a stimulus to a
massive deficit i mean how is that
economic conservatism and that actually
is more at home now with sort of
centrist corporate democrats right i
mean when you look at joe scarborough's
positions I'm not saying Joe Scarborough
is a you know sort of average Democrat
but the place for moderate Republicans
is probably the Democratic Party
increasingly I mean Lindsey Graham and
John McCain are examples they're only a
hair to the right of the the sort of
corporate Democrats it reminds me of
that SNL joke that the 2016 election
between was between Trump and the
Republican basically asserting that
Hillary Clinton is essentially a
Republican yeah
and while I didn't fully jump on board
with that on a lot of issues there were
certainly those neoliberal tendencies
from Hillary Clinton that are pretty
much indistinguishable so yeah you've
got far-right anti-science extremists in
the Republican Party you've got a center
to center right sort of status quo in
the Democratic Party and then you've got
this small wing of Democrats that are
actually what what somebody might call
truly progressive so in a way whatever
the the the point was of this big
announcement from Joe Scarborough
increasingly it's the center of the
Democratic Party that is the place for
people like Joe Scarborough it remember
this guy Bob ney I don't know if I've
interviewed him well you've been on the
program Bob ney is this former
Republican congressman who ended up
spending about 16 or 18 months in a
federal prison actually he was involved
in the Jack Abramoff could one of the
various Jack Abramoff corruption
scandals and he came out of prison and
and he spoke to us a number of times
about different elements of what was
going on on the right when you hear him
talk you don't think of him like if you
put Bob ney a lifelong Republican next
to I don't know who's like one of the
further right mains you know Republicans
right now had Cruz like a Ted Cruz tip
if you put Bob ney next to Ted Cruz it's
very hard to understand how they could
possibly be in the same party actually
when you hear Bob ney talk he sounds way
more like someone like I don't know Joe
Manchin for the sake of picking someone
on the right of the Democratic Party or
even some of the more centrist Democrats
going in the direction of Hillary
Clinton I get what Joe Scarborough is
talking especially because Joe
Scarborough served in Congress in the
late 90s early 2000s the Republican
Party was far different than the one we
have today drastically and I think he
may have even I don't remember what your
Scarborough he was like one of the
youngest people I think at the time Ron
around him remember might have been
closer to the early 90s but he was in
that and the House of Representatives
and that was a drastically different
Republican Party from what we have now
what will happen to the Republican Party
at the end of Donald Trump but just as
importantly and I talked about this
yesterday and the centrist corporate
Democrat discussion is relevant what's
going to happen to the Democratic Party
which
increasingly devouring itself during the
era of Donald Trump big questions that
hopefully we can answer soon